what's up everyone currently at Galleria
Delica damia and Firenze Italia Florence
Italy and as you can see behind me right
now is the Statue of David by
Michelangelo so this it was a massive
slab of marble that 500 years ago
Michelangelo
chiseled away at over a period of
approximately three or four years we
think and made that beautiful piece of
art so a couple other cool facts right
now you can't really tell but actually
that is five meters high about 17 feet
check out how big a human is
so that's the size of a human in
comparison to the statutes massive 17
feet tall 5 meters also this is just
check this out I'm gonna give you a
little like closer to a 360 ish
Washington
[Music]
and if you check out some of his
features check this out watch this
you see his eyes right there
super well done look at the hair look at
the ribcage look at the veins the pubic
hair look at his hands
veins on his legs his toes he's got a
support structure right there he's got a
support structure that that piece of
marble on the bottom as well as a little
tree as well he's not like it's hard to
see from here but you can see it right
there he's got like a little tree on the
back leg that helps a lot so I really
want us to to think about how incredible
it is to take years of our time to make
beautiful art like this and why it
matters so much for us to figure out why
it's important to do this and do it over
time more frequently inspire young kids
to do it to spend years of their time
learning how to do this by the way
another fun fact for you
so Michelangelo was the first artist
Italian artist to take a slab of marble
like this and envision the artwork
inside of the slab of marble previously
they were doing that supposedly they
weren't envisioning the art inside of
the slab of marble he was doing that and
what he would do is he would do the
whole front of the statue first so
you're like okay how does how does he
actually carve it over time well he
sculpts it over time by doing
the front first we would only do the
front first other people would work
around the statue over time but if you
messed up on a part you'd be pissed off
so he would get the front perfect first
genius idea also genius to envision the
final piece of art inside of the brick
of marble
oh yeah it's gorgeous I'm going to show
you the back as well on the way out of
there's a little bit of a line when we
get through
nor flash no flash please be respectful
yeah here's the bag check this out
so you know that's that support
structure right there gotta have the
support structure and then there's also
that that part of what looks like a tree
supporting it
and there's interestingly running from
the hand of his back is a little bit of
what looks like a little bit of like a
strap that's going from there to there
yeah looks amazing
so see you guys rock thanks for tuning
in and watching again we are at gallery
de academia in Florence in Firenze in
Italia and we are at the Statue of David
by Michelangelo so thanks everyone for
tuning in shoes are important to inspire
kids to make heart and to be creative we
need more of that in our lives and in
our world so go and inspire kids to be
creative and become artists look at this
get inspiration it's not some social
media dopamine instantaneously tomorrow
I get a million things this is you
invest years of your life and then it
lasts The Linde effect at last 300 500 a
thousand years into time so go and make
amazing art much love everyone thanks
you too